what is going on everybody welcome to
another basics Python tutorial video
this video is going to be concerning
another standard library module called
pickle so what is pickle what do we even
using it for and all that so pickle is a
serialization deserialization module
basically it converts Python objects to
byte stream and then back again cool so
what does that mean okay so basically
what it's doing is and in fact if you're
coming from other languages you might
know this is like flattening
serialization marshaling stuff like that
but in Python everyone's going to refer
to this as pickling so try not to use
those other words some people might not
even know what they mean
so pickling again is to use is used to
sort by Chthon objects so this could be
like a whole lot of things this could be
maybe an object you've created from a
class this could be a variable this
could be obviously a variable but this
could be like a list this could be all
kinds of things that you can pickle so
why might you want to pickle or winter
people using pickling an example from
our own tutorials is for example when
we've pickled a machine-learning
classifier so with machine learning when
you create a classifier you have to you
create it by training a classifier the
training process takes a while but what
you're your end result is an object and
that object is your classifier so you
have one of two choices you can either
somehow save that classifier or every
time you want it you actually have to go
back and retrain it every single time
that's inefficient so we use pickle so
we can pickle or serialize into byte
stream and then D pickle or DC relies
back to a Python object so let's go
ahead and just show a quick example
let's go ahead and import pickle another
example why you might use it too is say
you have a large data set that using
very frequently every time you read in a
data set either way you're connecting to
like a my sequel database maybe you've
got to CSV maybe you're just using a
flat file or something that read in
process is
takes a while and if you pickle it it's
going to be a whole lot faster so keep
that in mind it's going to be
I mean sometimes your loading time say
compared to JSON or pulling in from a
sequel database we're looking at fifty
to a hundred plus sometimes up to a
thousand or more times faster so it's
useful just for anything that requires a
lot of processing and ends in an object
okay so anyways importing pickle uh next
thing let's just create an example
dictionary so we'll say example dict
equals something unless just say it's
one colon something to colon something
and then three colon looks cool in
something and then let's just put some
arbitrary things in there good so now we
have our example dictionary now how will
we output this or how do we pickle this
well we can do something like this
pickle out is going to equal open and we
want to open dicks dot pickle and we're
going to open it with the intention not
only to write bubble writing bytes so WB
four bytes if you're coming from Python
to seven and you're watching this and
you refused to make the switch to three
just know you don't really need this
this is a requirement for three so now
you've got pickle out now that we have
this pickle out file what we're going to
do is we're going to say pickle dot dump
so here we're referencing the pickle
module so pickle dot dump and then we
pass some parameters first of all what
do we want to dump well we want to dump
the example dictionary and then the
second parameter where do we want to
dump it we want to dump it to pickle out
save that and then don't forget
obviously after you write anything two
files go ahead close it so let's say
pickle underscore out close before we
make those mistakes and that will save
something to this Dix dot pickle it'll
go in the same directory as your script
feel free to go check there if you want
now how do we load the pickle back in so
how do we deep pickle something well we
basically go through a pretty similar
path
in fact let me pull up let's pull up the
pickle this is the pickle here let's
open it with notepad take a peek okay so
that doesn't really quite look like
anything we could read but that is you
know our information is just we don't
recognize it ourselves makes a whole lot
of sense to the computer though so
anyways that aside let's close this down
how do we read that dictionary back into
memory well let me go ahead and just
comment those out if you don't know how
to comment bulk its highlight everything
alt 3 and that will bulk comment
something
so now let's pickle in so we're going to
save pickle whoops
pickle underscore in equals open and
then we're going to open that same file
ticked dot pickle and we want to open it
with the intention to read they'll read
what bytes so now we have the pickle and
then we're gonna we just now we have
that all we had to do is we're just
going to say a pickle load so we would
say something like this example picked
so we're just calling it the same thing
but again this is all commented out so
it's doing nothing example ticked equals
pickle dot load what do we want to load
we want to load this pickle in file and
that's that so now what we can do is we
could say let's just print the example
dick and then to prove that it is indeed
acting as if as the object that it truly
is because when you save an object it
also saves the data type and the object
side and all that so to prove that let's
just do print example dicks and then to
so if you recall this would be the key
of two so we should return a value of
two I have no idea what just happened
there I have never used this every point
clear point anyway
example dick to print that out so we can
see that it's acting like a dictionary
sure enough here is our dictionary and
here is our value we can also do like
three just so we can get a different
number or or letter actually I used F so
that's pickling that's why you would
pickle and it's pretty useful the only
caveat you should take note is you might
use pickles to transfer data between
maybe some servers or you might pick up
a pickle
or you might pickle some data from
another source it's unlikely that you're
just going to parse a website that has
pickle or anything but you are going to
you might have it being transferred by a
network pickle has no security in place
so you load that object you run that
object you better be certain about the
security of that of that object
otherwise you're going to run some you
could run some malicious code so anyways
that's pickle
in the next tutorial we're going to be
talking about eval which is sort of like
pickle if you wanted to save something
into a string form or something like
that but it's more commonly used if you
want to read someone else's string
version of something but anyways that's
what's up next if you have any questions
or comments on this video please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time